you you talk about this a lot but just
the whole [ __ ] max situation [ __ ] max
always on no jumper but yeah
you're a hoover
he's got hoover killer on his forehead
do you get the email that says
from this time to this time this guy
will be here
don't pull up
yeah they not gonna make it happen
they're not gonna do that that's crazy
like
i'm like this is a young [ __ ] first of
all he just young you know what i'm
saying i don't think he really got it
all
and you know it just it ain't that time
yet but
i was like you know what i was telling
adam because he really [ __ ] with him
you know just as a person because when i
look at his interviews or when i look at
his vlogs and all that [ __ ] and i see
his how hospitable he can be like his
hospitality and going out there and
talking to people and having respect for
the elder folks and giving away to the
homeless and [ __ ] like he's a whole
different type of [ __ ] but when he turn
on that gang bang switch
it's like super disrespectful and it's
just like crazy but i can see why
adam might like him because that's the
um cmac that he know you know what i'm
saying even though he has ignorant
content and [ __ ] like that i was like
but he got that showing his forehead cuz
i can never
talk to that [ __ ] i can never [ __ ] with
him you can't be around or whatever i'm
like but he gonna see i'm like one day
he gonna understand and then one day he
hit adam
you like should i interview i interview
with her
or you know or i'll do a skit with cod
and i'm like i said i see [ __ ] no [ __ ]
but i see i was like see he growing you
feel me because all that clout and all
this [ __ ] like you want to keep that
[ __ ] going you know what i'm saying you
want to be successful for longer and
you're starting to feel like you got to
reach out to different people you got to
start [ __ ] with people even if
they're your enemies [ __ ] you feel me
to get that content out but
with that [ __ ] on your forehead that
[ __ ] gonna hold you back [ __ ]
you feel like there's like a fine line
though between like because when i saw
what happened with dude like when he got
dp'ed and like
i mean
i feel like it sucks because like he's
kind of been made into this internet
personality
and the and the and we forget that he's
also a member of a gang and like
there's consequences for maybe some of
the stuff that he feels like he has to
do for views or for the clout you just
mentioned
so i kind of almost feel like it's just
it's just a weird situation i'm sorry i
felt kind of it's not that i felt sorry
for him but i just felt like
damn like there there's there this is
how this was going to end up the whole
time based on one one i know they
they're gonna it's gonna put a little
extra on it because you is who you is
now
and two it's just it's game banging
that's what it is you gotta i mean
you're gonna get dp'd i mean and that's
just what the [ __ ] it is like [ __ ] and
they filmed it a little bit [ __ ] oh well